voici les nommés dans la catégorie
premier rôle masculin comédie
ces présentations sont maintenant chose
du passé homme femme et personne non
binaire seront désormais regroupés dans
une même catégorie qui passera de 5 à 8
finalistes et le gagne et ça fait très
longtemps que et l'industrie et
les membres demandent à ce qui est moins
de catégorie pour rajouter de la valeur
au prix mais la nouvelle mouture soulève
des questions en matière de parité
homme-femme
dans cinq ans que 80% des trophées ont
été remis ou des nominations étaient mis
à des hommes
plus ou moins réussi c'est ça qu'il faut
éviter en fait l'organisation des
Gémeaux n'a pas prévu de mécanisme à cet
effet mais promet de s'ajuster en
fonction du prochain gala d'abord il
faut dire que cette décision des Gémeaux
n'est pas complètement indépendante
parce que l'Académie canadienne du
cinéma et de la télévision la grande
sœur de la section québécoise avait déjà
adopté les prix non j'en ris pour le
gala des écrans Canadiens c'est aussi
une décision de faire comment redonner
du tonus à cette cérémonie là sachant
que l'ensemble des cérémonies de remise
de prix un peu partout perdent de
l'audience
les disques préfèrent maintenir la
catégorie interprète féminine estimant
que la parité au sein de l'industrie de
la musique était encore bien fragile et
que le temps n'était pas encore venu de
retirer 5 nominations prestigieuses aux
femmes en musique
les trophées non j'en ris ouvre
néanmoins la porte à une plus grande
diversité de genre il y aura plus de
limite c'est l'ouverture à la diversité
mis à part les catégories masculines et
féminines les Gémeaux abolissent une
cinquantaine de prix qui sont jugés trop
similaires l'Académie va donc distribuer
88 statuettes au lieu des 139 habituels
pour un gala de plus courte durée ici
Jean Philippe piouze Radio-Canada
Montréal